What’s up Wisecrack, Helen here! It’s
been a minute, but Jared’s giving me the
mic today to get brainy with you about Big
Mouth, the Netflix series that puts a spotlight
on everyone’s most discomforting season
of life: Puberty.
A few of you have asked us to cover Big Mouth
but coming up with a good angle admittedly
hasn’t been easy. On the surface, Big Mouth
isn’t the most profound thing in the world.
I mean, it’s basically what you’d get
if the Simpsons and Degrassi gave birth to
a weird sex ed class that’s set to the tune
of catchy parody songs about menstrual blood
and “doing sex” on a woman.
“Hey Rick, it’s not weird that I haven’t,
y’know, done sex yet, right?”
But we saw a couple possible angles from a
neuroscience and psychology standpoint that
maybe sorta kinda work, which is why I’m
here to walk you through ‘em. So, grab your
bag of dicks and hold on tight for this half-baked
breakdown of Big Mouth. And yes, spoilers
ahead.
But before we get to that, wanna let you guys
know this video is sponsored by Betterhelp,
the online counseling service. You might be
aware that there was some controversy surrounding
the company. We’re aware too and have addressed
these concerns in our Philosophy of True Detective
video. The link’s in the description, if
you want to check it out. Long story short,
we all believe in the value of speaking to
someone on a regular basis and we think Betterhelp
is a good option for people who think online
therapy is the right fit for them. So, stick
around till the end of the video for more
info, and now back to the show.
Ok, so, for those of you who haven’t seen
the show, here’s a quick rundown.
Big Mouth covers all your standard puberty
plots. In season 1, our heroes have their
first kisses, wrangle with their sexuality,
knock up a bean-filled pillow - you know,
typical teenager stuff. Most of this is on
account of the Hormone Monsters, big hairy
creatures who are constantly telling our heroes
how to live their lives and, more importantly,
where to put their genitals [“There we go,
visualize, focus, interesting, yeeeeess”].
In season 2, they’re basically doing the
same things, but with a new shoulder devil
thrown in the mix: The Shame Wizard.
All these youthful foibles gave us our first
pitch: The crazy pubescent brain.
Scientists find Human adolescents fascinating
for a reason: Their rapidly-changing brains
make them like no other creature on Earth.
In the words of neuroscientist Frances Jensen,
teenagers are “like Ferraris with weak brakes,”
which is why they’re more prone than adults
are to doing erratic shit, like giving in
to the thrill of shoplifting or running away
with your not-boyfriend and his pillow-slash-baby
mama [Pam? Scorpion? Jay? Who are these pillows?
We’re his family. Who the F*ck are you b*tch?].
That’s because the part of the brain that’s
responsible for what we call “executive
functioning” - which includes things like
making rational decisions - isn’t all the
way developed yet. All of this madness kicks
off during puberty, when the brain begins
to undergo a whole lotta changes that will
eventually turn you into a grown-ass human
being - maybe [Oh, Hey Nick! Coach Steve?
How ‘bout an awkward reaching fist bump
my dude? What are you doing here? Oh. I still
go to the pediatrician. I am what is known
in the medical community as a man-baby. You’re
the man-baby Steve.].
And you might be saying, no shit. While scientific
explanations of something we all mostly know
is a worthwhile endeavor, it’s not exactly
a Wisecrack video. So, I’m gonna give that
pitch like a C-.
That leaves us with our second almost-angle:
Shame.
There was a bit of buzz around the Shame Wizard
when Season 2 debuted last fall, because A)
David Thewlis, AKA Professor Lupin from Harry
Potter, voices the Shame Wizard and does a
kick-ass job, and B) the character is just
so good and something all of us have dealt
with.
But apart from throwing a wet blanket on the
Hormone Monsters’ schemes, does the Shame
Wizard actually reflect our lived experience
of shame in a unique and thought-provoking
manner?
Well, what IS shame, anyway? It may be best
described by contrasting it with guilt. Now,
guilt is feeling bad about something that
we’ve done, while shame is feeling like
we’re fundamentally flawed as the people
we are. Or, as the Shame Wizard puts it during
Andrew’s trial: [“Now the state shall
prove that Andrew Glouberman didn’t do a
bad thing. Yeah. He is a bad thing! Oh.”,]
So, along with all the warm fuzzy feelings
of first love or lust or whatever, puberty
also brings an awful lot of shameful self-loathing.
It’s a common refrain that the older you
get, the fewer fucks you give. And in that
vein, Big Mouth asks: How does our shame change
as we age? [“You’re just a thirteen-year-old
man who took what he wanted. Ah. Like me,
I live balls out and I give zero f*cks”]
The Shame Wizard shows up as a little voice
in Andrew’s head after he gets caught jerking
off over Leah’s swimsuit [It’s going to
be fine. No, it’s not. What? She saw everything.
Who said that? She’s going to tell everyone.”].
He proceeds to follow the kids around berating
them for the things they do, much to the chagrin
of the hormone monsters [“Just give the
kid a night off. Give all the kids a night
off.”]. But as far as the show tells us,
the Shame Wizard doesn’t have any power
over adults. Despite the fact that their behavior
is way more messed up, like Jessi’s mom
cheating on her dad and then banishing him
to the basement and Jay’s parents generally
being sleezy assholes [“I will happily abandon
my family to get you the divorce settlement
that you deserve.”]. I mean the poor guy’s
mom gets drunk and forgets to pick him up
from school on a daily basis, then sleeps
with his teacher, all while his dad is out
banging other women and getting criminals
off the hook. And these adults all seem to
avoid shame court.
This gets really interesting in the context
of the relationship between the Shame Wizard
and clinically-certified man child Coach Steve.
He’s the only adult that we see interacting
with Shame, and he’s apparently immune to
it, even though he sleeps with the mother
of his student and so-called best friend and
knocks out a fellow teacher with a bat. You
might say the Shame Wizard can’t get to
Coach Steve because he’s just plain dumb.
But even if that’s the case, it still doesn’t
change the fact that the teens are the only
ones who are visibly tormented by the Shame
Wizard.
But for the sake of science, was 13-year-old
you just being melodramatic when you felt
like holing yourself up for the rest of your
life after you called your English teacher
Mom? Or was your brain actually conspiring
against you?
While admittedly there’s not a ton of clear-cut
evidence that teenagers are more shame-ridden
than adults, there is some. Susceptibility
to shame decreased as kids entered young adulthood
in one study, something the researchers thought
might have to do with the fact that as your
brain matures, it’s better able to regulate
emotions. And this makes sense when you think
about how teens process emotions compared
to adults. Teens are known to pick up on social
and emotional cues that adults just filter
out. They also spend more time thinking about
the way others see them, traits that psychologists
think are from an evolutionary standpoint
supposed to help them make friends. This has
the unfortunate side effect of making them
a lot more easily embarrassed and maybe even
ashamed. In a kind of creepy study where people
were told that they were being monitored over
video, teens were more likely to report feeling
embarrassed than either adults or children.
And parts of the brain associated with social
emotions were a lot more active in teens during
this scenario.
Some scientists think this might have to do
with the influx of hormones during puberty,
aka the hormone monsters showing up. So theoretically,
being rejected as a teenager is harder to
swallow than when you’re an adult because
your brain is more sensitive to social emotions,
making the whole experience a lot more painful.
Big Mouth also does a really great job of
highlighting the relationship between shame
and depression. The Shame Wizard antagonizes
pretty much all the kids at some point, but
none of them are hit quite as hard as Jessi.
All she wants is for her family to be together,
but she winds up responsible for her dad getting
kicked out of the house after she steals his
weed gummies. The Shame Wizard bears down
on her hard [“Was it worth it Jessi? Just
to get hella faded” “No”], only to return
in full force after she slut shames Gina.
Gina refuses to forgive her and calls her
a hypocrite, ultimately leading to Connie
being replaced by the Depression Kitty and
Jessi being locked away in a padded room in
the Department of Puberty [“I should get
up, it’s kind of weird to be in bed in the
middle of the day” “No it’s not”].
Both guilt and shame are linked to depression,
but it’s been argued that shame might be
more potent in actually causing depression
than guilt.
That idea kind of offers an explanation for
why Jessi is the only major character who
winds up depressed, despite the fact that
shame impacts everyone. Obviously, her home
life is significantly more messed up than
anyone else’s, except maybe for Jay. But
I’d argue that Jessi’s shame runs a lot
deeper than that of her friends, because the
consequences of her actions reflect more negatively
on her character than her friends’ do. Even
though Andrew feels shame for being a quote
“pervert,” his masturbation habits can
easily be adjusted [“Actually I don’t
think I am going to jerk off inches from my
best friend’s face tonight. I am better
than that”]. But Jessi can’t go back and
fix the things that lead her to believe she’s
a bad daughter and a hypocrite. That combined
with the fact that her family’s support
is kind of lacking, makes her more prone to
depression, something she can only get out
of - literally - with the help of her friends
[“Yeah, the men saved her” “ugh”].
In the end, Big Mouth tells us that the best
way to deal with shame is communication. [“I
do need help. I wanna talk to that therapist.]
While having a free-for-all at a middle school
sleepover isn’t exactly the most practical
solution, being willing to talk about the
way we feel keeps us from feeling alone. After
all, whether you’re an awkward middle schooler
in the throes of puberty or a famously dead
jazz phenomenon, life... is a f*cked up mess.
[“Life is a f*cked up mess. Life is a f*cked
up mess.”]. We’d might as well laugh about
it.
So yeah, I’m gonna give that pitch a solid
B. That’s partly because shame is admittedly
the low-hanging fruit here. Sure, we can cite
studies that confirm our basic understanding
of shame all day, but it’s kind of one note.
Maybe the Shame Wizard could’ve broached
the idea that shame has some benefits for
your psyche and society at large, an idea
that’s been argued by psychologists and
philosophers alike. The kids sort of touch
on that at the close of season 2 [“I wanna
be a good person too, I do” “Oh, you do,
you see, we’re not so different, are we?”]
but they don’t really explore it in any
meaningful way, so we don’t have enough
detail for a meaty discussion.
Still, Big Mouth really kills its illustration
of the power of shame during puberty. And
smart stuff aside, if you’re a Homo Sapien
who has or is currently going through puberty,
Big Mouth is really relatable.
But what do you think, Wisecrack? Is a whole
video on the Rock of Gibraltar in order, or
is there some other hot take you guys wanna
see? Drop us a line in the comments, [“ho
ho ho. You think you’re excited? I just
found out Dip n’ Dots isn’t fluorescent
guinea pig doodies”] and before you go this
episode is sponsored by Betterhelp, the Online
Counseling service. Betterhelp operates worldwide
to pair people with licensed professionals
who they can talk to on their computer, tablet,
phone, whatever. As I said earlier you might
be aware that there was some controversy surrounding
the company last year. We’ve been following
it closely and we’re still confident that
Betterhelp is a good option for people who
think online therapy is the right fit for
them. For a full breakdown of the issues brought
up, please reference the end of our True Detective
video. We’ve popped a link in the description.
I’m all about breaking down the stigma of
getting help for mental health issues and
something I really like about Betterhelp is
how it makes it easy to get counseling for
people who might otherwise feel uncomfortable
about therapy. Everyone in the office has
tried their service, they’ve liked it, and
some are still using it regularly. The certified
counselor I was paired with was attentive,
professional, and smart - definitely on par
with any local therapists I’ve seen.
Having said that, even in real life, you don’t
always click with your therapist. Trust me.
I’ve been there. And then you have to schedule
another appointment in another office, which
can be super discouraging - not to mention
take forever. But that’s one of the great
things about Betterhelp. If for whatever reason,
you don’t connect with your therapist, you
can get paired with another professional in
under 24 hours. And if you’re at all dissatisfied
with your experience, Betterhelp is offering
a full refund. So, if online counseling sounds
like a good fit for you, go to betterhelp.com/wisecrack
to get paired with a certified professional
within 24 hours.
And with that, I’m out. Peace.